une vingtaine de mesures pour défendre
l'esprit d'entreprise et favoriser la
croissance c'est la proposition de
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés l'association a rédigé un livre
blanc qu'elle a remis le 22 juin nicolas
sarkozy président du parti les
républicains un ouvrage élaboré à partir
de discussions entre entrepreneurs et
figures politiques il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se disent même en france très
bien qu'ils parlent très bien mais qui
ne comprennent pas qu'ils ne connaissent
pas les réalités de l'économie
mondialisée
là c'est vraiment gênant fonderie c'est
des gens qui comprennent qu'ils viennent
de la médiation qui aiment la france qui
aime l'entreprise française nous
proposons plus de stabilité plus de
cohérence de souplesse et le livre blanc
insuffle ce vent de liberté dont notre
pays a besoin
baisser les charges sur les entreprises
privilégier le numérique ou mettre en
place un contrat de travail unique
autant de projets détaillés dans ce
livre blanc génération entreprises
misent sur une hyper croissance des
mesures qui seront évoquées
prochainement par le parti continuer à
investir dans ce travail et de juillet
au fond c'est nationale on présente
l'ensemble pour qu'ils choisissent le
pilote français qui se disent dans leur
prochain d'une place un entrepreneur
quand il a des moyens
il investit quand il a pas de moyens ils
avaient sipa il crée pas d'emplois une
nouvelle vague de création massive
d'emplois passe bas la confiance entre
l'état et l'entreprise et les français
génération entreprise groupe de travail
fondée en 2002 compte à ce jour plus de
150 parlementaires députés et sénateurs
depuis sa création de nombreux
amendements ont été adoptés notamment
sur l'assurance vie